welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and if you've been on
Twitter in the last hour then you've
probably seen that there's been a major
development in the Jonathan major case
now personally I've been getting hit up
so much to cover this story and every
time I've been asked about it I've said
look I'm going to wait until the trial
proceeds and comes to its conclusion
because I always think it should be
innocent until proven guilty this case
has been a great example of how the
court of public opinion can jump back
and forth as we've had people switching
sides constantly once the story changes
personally I think it's best to just
always kind of keep your mouth closed
because these are quite sensitive
subjects and if you put a foot wrong it
it can make you look really bad as well
so I I've wanted to keep quiet on this
but since the story's dropped I've just
been getting been getting hit up so much
on Twitter so I thought I'd go through
it and just kind of talk about what's
happening now Jonathan Maes has been
found guilty of harassment and assault
as of today with a Manhattan jury coming
to that conclusion this includes two
MISD demean accounts of harassment and
assault but he has been acquitted on two
other counts now all of this comes from
variety um I must admit I'm not 100%
familiar with how American law works you
know being British myself um I've been
told that this is basically the the
equivalent of gross bodily harm but
whether that's the case or not I'll
leave it to you guys in the comments to
correct me and apologies if I mess up
any of this but I'll try I'm reading
mainly from the Variety article so I'll
try and be as thorough as possible now
he was found guilty on one count of
intentional assault in the third degree
and aggravated harassment in the second
degree now this decision comes from a
six-person jury who actually requested
to hear the definition of harassment in
the second degree just to spell it out
this is what the report says it states
that's an intent to harass a night or
alarm this is in a case when either a
person strikes someone shoves them kicks
them or otherwise and there's physical
contact made where someone threatens to
do that to someone now it's been a very
strange case because there's been a lot
of PR coming from Major's side in which
his defense have said they've got got
evidence that's going to completely
clear his name as that came out though
public opinion on it changed and people
have obviously been internet sleuths and
completely overanalyzing everything
Marvel themselves have very much took a
step back and they've not issued a
statement about what's going on however
we have heard rumors behind the scenes
that when it comes to K they will be
continuing with the character but he
might just get recast I know talking
about Marvel that shouldn't really be
the main focus of stuff as it is a very
serious issues but OB obviously you know
the subscribers of this Channel they
follow me for that reason so we have to
at least touch on that a bit going
forward I actually thought with the end
of luy season 2 that Kang was going to
be pushed off into the corner and if
Jonathan Major's name was clear then
they'd bring him back in they played it
in a way where it could really go in
either Direction with the TVA keeping an
eye on him if it went the way that it's
gone the way they've left things though
they're still continuing with Kang
Dynasty and also Secret Wars with
Michael Waldren now writing the scripts
for them so with all that effort put
into it I'm sure Marvel are keeping the
character and behind the scenes you know
they've obviously weighed up what could
be happening though they said they
haven't discussed Rec casting Mages at
all I think that's not the case and I
think there will have been conversations
where they weighed up the options Kang
is of course a multiversal character and
though Mages has played every version of
him so far it's not like they can't
bring another actor in and replace him
now again I do feel like I'm getting
away from the serious stuff by even
talking about K so let's go back to the
case and just focus on that so
prosecutor Kelly Galloway alleged that
Mages was manipulative been controlling
through their 2-year relationship which
culminated on March 25th during the
altercation in the car along with voice
recordings jury members were also shown
messages between the pair where majes
had threatened to end his own life over
a disagreement he also tried to dissuade
Jabari from going to the hospital to
treat a head wound and in the end it
didn't look good for him Galloway's
closing statement also led into this
heavily as they said what this really
boils down to is four simple words
control domination manipulation and
abuse those are the tactics used by
Those who commit domestic violence
against Partners against Grace now on
the other side of this major defense
said it was Jabari who assaulted him in
the first place making things the other
way around that's why this case has been
so confusing because we've seen so much
conflicting evidence and heard stories
that are basically telling the opposite
sides of each other you've got both
accusing the other of assault with
mages' Team calling Jabari Elia who just
bends reality again variety have done a
really breakdown on this and in the end
we're kind of left wondering well what
happens next there is possible jail time
that could come from this with major
potentially serving up to a year in
prison that sentence will be delivered
in February so we do have a couple of
months to kind of see how things are
going to go although we don't know what
the sentence is going to be for definite
a lot of people that have spoken to me
have said that if he goes to jail it's
going to be for a very short time it is
difficult to predict how hard they're
going to go on him but people who are
well versed in the subject of contacted
me I'm actually recording this after
editing the whole thing just to add it
in but they said he's basically being
convicted of two misdemeanor with the
max sentence for that being about a year
so if he does get jail time that will be
the full sentence however a lot of
people have spoken to me and said they
think it's very unlikely that he's going
to get that full term that's even if he
gets jail time as Sal in the third
degrees it's quite a common thing to get
charged with and um from what I've been
told on Twitter that the jury didn't
actually find any evidence of assault
with intention it was just Reckless
assault so the intention thing is what
people tend to focus on so in the end it
might not be too harsh of a sentence if
it comes down to it however you have to
also view things from a PR term and I
can imagine that at Marvel now they're
having a bit of a nightmare mages'
career now it's pretty much screwed and
it's insane to think how how much is
Star Wars on the rise last year remember
he had two movies that were backtack
number one in the world with Ant-Man 3
and Creed 3 as well there was also a lot
of hype behind magazine dreams which was
acquired by search like pictures at this
year's sundance's Film Festival however
that's been removed from its upcoming
release schedule and it's difficult to
think that the guy's going to repair his
career from this being found guilty in
something like this is really really
damaging and even just the allegations
alone they can completely destroy your
career so Court coming to this
conclusion it looks really bad and I I
don't really know how how else this can
go other than him getting fired now a
lot of people on Twitter they're talking
about Josh Brolin as he was also an MCU
villain but he had a similar controversy
happened in his career sorry life I
should say life inste of career there um
I think the difference is just the
social climate at the moment and people
are far more focused on this with
obviously social media movements as well
picking up these stories if Josh brolan
did it now I think it would be a
different story and yeah that that's
just something to consider when we're
going over this story it's also one of
those situations where a lot of people
are bringing in their own personal
feelings into this as you've got issues
like race um celebrity gender and lots
of different aspects playing into it for
example there's some people who think he
was persecuted because he's a successful
black man there were some people who
were on Grace jabari's side thinking
this is a powerful man who's going to
get away with doing something heinous
and lots of people bringing their own
personal feelings into it Disney is of
course trying to be a familyfriendly
company and to have this person leading
their biggest franchises it's big bad
it's going to be a PR nightmare so and
people are asking me what I think is
going to happen next and yeah I think
the guy probably will get fired now
obviously there's people on the other
side of this who are saying they don't
understand how they've came to this
conclusion for example the driver was on
Jonathan Ma's side and we have seen the
CCTV that shows him trying to run away
from the situation all in all it's a
very complicated situation that I'm not
going to weigh in too much with my
personal opinion but this is the
conclusion that the jury have come to so
yeah it's very very very difficult to
kind of weigh on this as well because
you know it's such a serious thing to be
dealing with and I don't want to just be
throwing jokes in there um and obviously
people are going to have their opinions
so so this is me putting it over to you
guys what do you think please keep it
respectful as well and yeah drop them in
the comments Below on what you think the
whole situation is I know people are
going to talk about Marvel and K as well
but yeah please just try and keep it
respectful because there are people
reading this who who will be quite
triggered by it so yeah thank you for
all your support anyway on this and like
I said I've been keeping my mouth shut
on it until we got this this verdict and
yeah I was shocked when I read it you
know I had been following the case uh I
was in my mind I was kind of thinking
you know it it's not looking good um but
even to get this verdict it was a very
big shock so yeah um leave your thoughts
below I know it's not the type of thing
that we normally cover but um yeah just
leave your thoughts below as love to
hear from you guys so without the way
thank you and I'll see you on the next
one